[Musique]
ma vie tellez casini rieuse bonjour
bonjour monsieur vie volerie et bonjour
à tous les martiniquais qui nous
écoutent et puis je salue
particulièrement les points 3 qui vivra
au de martinique qui nous écoutent aussi
vous êtes quand vous êtes la maire
sortante de basse-pointe vous êtes
candidate à votre propre succession 2020
vous avez été élus en 2014 puis réélu en
mars 2019
lors des élections partielles ça fait un
peu beaucoup non marie thérèse casimir
yeux sur beaucoup scrutin li li points 3
ceux là sont tous alors je ne vais pas
parler des points toi je pense qu'il
faudrait alors posé la gamme en ce qui
me concerne j'ai toujours considéré que
l'élection de mars 2010neuf c'était une
élection tout à fait illégal alors en un
mot dites nous pourquoi vous considérez
cette mission mais simplement au regard
de la loi il semblerait qu' il y avait
un délai dans un délai d'un an y avait
pas nécessité absolue de procéder à de
nouvelles élections
enfin bon je suis quand même
respectueuse des procédures et ça nous a
permis au contraire ça m'a permis au
contraire d'augmenter le score de 2014
est-ce que ce que l'adversaire principal
de cette élection ne risque pas d'être
l'abstention je ne pense pas je pense
bien au contraire il y a on a constaté
qu'il y a nous leur candidature et je
crois que la population un petit peu
agacé de cette situation et elle va bien
au contraire
l'enfant a aussi son choix en mars 2020
alors vous l'avez dit vous allez
conduire la liste dynamique points 3 si
je ne la fais cela que vous êtes
investis par le ppm
tout à fait et à basse pointe on
dénombre pas moins de cinq candidats je
crois que c'est un record d'ailleurs
alors je n'ai pas si vous expliquer ça
aux bains je viens de le dire je dise
que simplement je pense que on est donc
nous sommes dans probablement d'après
les rumeurs dans des stratégies
électoralistes
où tout serait fait pour obtenir un
deuxième tour est possédée à une
alliance contre nature mais je crois que
les martiniquais et les maintiens que
les parties comment les points 3 ont
déjà vu le résultat de ces alliances
malsaines et odieux de la population je
crois qu'elle est la population
pointoise notamment cassé ou au bel et
bien aguerris face à sur ce genre de
situation l'objectif pour vous c'est que
ça se règle au premier tour alors mais
je suis convaincu que ce sera réglé dès
le premier tour
est ce que le nombre de candidats ça ne
signifie pas que qui j'ai une certaine
division aussi dans la commune je ne
dirais pas division parce que selon les
goûts vers vous avez beaucoup de
candidats qui se disent de gauche c'est
là que c'est incompréhensible on la
population mais je pense plutôt que nous
avons procédé aux gardes d'autres bilans
à une ouverture elle c'était
l'engagement qui a été pris et de
l'attractivité à basse-pointe enfoncé la
pratique du ppp le partenariat public
privé pour nous permettre justement
d'atteindre cet objectif sai son
attractivité du territoire
donc nous avons mis en exergue certains
noms de savoir faire et est apparemment
je pense que beaucoup de personnes
veulent venir sont attirés par cette
nouvelle image et la ville de basse
pointe que beaucoup semblent découvrir
alors vous avez commencé vous allez
poursuivre dans votre lancée quels
seront les grands chantiers que si vous
être élu mais à les relancer
là le premier grand chantier bien
évidemment si d'assurer la continuité de
ce que nous avons commencé notamment
terminer la réhabilitation de l'église
mais un nouveau chantier qui est très
important qui va nous permettre de
placer justement le point 3 au coeur de
nos préoccupations
sait on a souvent dit j'ai souvent dit
il fallait ou à penser basse pointe nous
sommes confrontés à un problème au
niveau de la sécurité
un problème sécuritaire par rapport à
l'érosion de la falaise et nous sommes
en possession de travaux d'architecte
c'est une commande qui a été passée à au
ministère de l'écologie de transition
plus exactement la transition écologique
et qui va nous permettre de repenser
basse pointe parce que je pense que
c'est là vraiment le noeud du problème
on ne peut pas se lancer dans des
chantiers nous avons bien évidemment
continuer les chantiers que nous avons
entamé des habitations nous de l'église
une création nouvelle crise municipale
et puis surtout lorsque j'ai pas de
sécurité un nouveau complexe scolaire
mais nous allons on va définir parce
qu'il faut il va falloir probablement à
redéfinir le réseau routier
l' axe routier majeur de la vie dure et
toi ça veut dire quoi on reste toujours
sur la sécurité ça veut dire être
repensé le bourg déplacer le gourou a
passé de bois ou à penser le sens du
transport et surtout ou à penser le
logement entrez dans une ce que nous
avons commencé avec des bailleurs
sociaux dans une nouvelle politique de
roy logement parce que certaines
habitations sont vraiment un grand
danger
marie thérèse casimir youth merci c'est
ma promesse